[Music]
this is Charlie manx the villain and
AMC's new series Nosferatu he's played
by sometimes bald actor Zachary Quinto
and was designed by this guy
oscar-winning FX artist Joel Harlow
Joel's work has been seen in tons of
great movies like all five of the
Pirates of the Caribbean films the first
JJ Abrams Star Trek Lone Ranger Logan
the new Hellboy Black Panther I visited
his workspace to learn how he brought
Charlie Manx to life and we looked at
some of his other amazing creations yo
um the new Hellboy I was approached by
production about doing a
transformational age makeup on Zach
Quentin who I've worked with on several
films obviously both Star Trek films in
Nosferatu Charlie makes a supernatural
creature who feeds up the souls of
children kidnapping them in a car called
the wraith with the vanity plate NOS for
a - or Nosferatu it's based on a novel
of the same name by author Joe Hill son
of award-winning author Tabitha King and
some guy named Steve and what you see
here is a silicone head of Zach once the
makeup is sculpted you know what you
have let's just say we're talking about
the hundred year old once the entire
makeup is sculpted on the stone copy of
Zach's head then you decide where you're
gonna cut the makeup apart cut the neck
off will cut the shin and lower lip off
will cut the upper lip and nose off
cheeks forehead and ear lobes and then
when you're dealing with a hundred and
thirty-five year old there's a back of
the head because his hair at that point
is so thin that you see through the hair
to the scalp creating a character from a
popular book is no easy task
luckily for Joel he knew the author they
met in 1994 when both were working on
the TV miniseries of the stand well
fortunately I am friends with Joe Hill
he's the go-to guy I mean he
max one of his biggest notes to me was
Max's teeth even when he's in his
earlier stages are still very sort of
desiccated it's like 1800s dental work
how much does when designing this did
Zacks actual character of his face play
into making oh it played into his
character right off the bat you know and
I never liked to design a makeup
independently of the actor or actress
that is playing that character it's
always very collaborative so there's a
lot of a lot of restraint required when
you're doing something like that as
opposed to doing a movie like Star Trek
beyond where you're creating aliens and
nobody's saying I've got a lot of leeway
there Hellboy you got a lot of leeway
there it's not a character that you see
at the store unless you're shopping
somewhere very unusual I do weird
appearing in a home when a normal life
it's a lot of just dialing it in so it
looks like a believable old-age
character yet maintains the
characteristics of in this case is AK I
would Texas AK images of the designs you
know and get his sign off so he was very
involved as you know most of the
performers I deal with are in in there
look you spend all this time in their
studio sculpting something sculpting a
character bring it to set you apply it
but it's not until it starts to move as
that character that it really comes to
life and I don't know if you know any
hundred thirty-five year old people but
I don't 135 does give you a little bit
of lead ya know it's like you can push
it a little bit there but yeah he's like
proved they don't do this whereas Joel
had little to reference when designing
Charlie Manx he had the opposite
challenge with another movie he recently
worked on Hellboy I got to try on a few
Hellboy accoutrements
a new Hellboy let's reboot it again
I'm ready go getting into this stuff is
harder than it looks
age 100 was about three to
three-and-a-half hours to get them all
ready yeah I mean it's long to get this
done correctly because it is an old age
and it is a realistic makeup it took
what it took and that was about three to
three and a half Nosferatu
trying to do four stages of an aging
makeup that looks absolutely believable
is very difficult you know that's a
challenge that's big challenge you're
trying to fool people in real life and
you know once you do that you know
you're gonna be able to fool them on
film